located on the sunny south of France
picturesque Avignon was once the seat of
power for the Catholic Church the
historic center of Avignon is known for
its architectural and cultural
significance both of which largely stem
from its brief stint as a seat of the
papacy Ivan Yuans role as residents of
the Pope's was relatively short-lived
the Avignon papacy or Babylonian
captivity as some dubbed it was
controversial within the church and
lasted only from 1309 to 1377 but it
left behind a lasting imprint on the
city beginning in 1335 a magnificent
palace was constructed to house the
Pope's completed in less than twenty
years in two phases the Palais de PAP is
the largest gothic palace in Europe the
palace also holds a collection of
intricate frescoes by the Italian master
Mateo Giovannetti 7 popes occupy the
palace before the papacy moved back to
Rome in 1377 with the palace and Avignon
were main property of the papacy until
the French Revolution when it was seized
by revolutionaries it was later
converted into military barracks and a
prison under Napoleon today the property
is preserved as a museum and visitors
can stroll through its halls in gander
at the former private chambers of the
Pope the palace is surrounded by other
monuments including the Cathedral of
Notre Dame de dôme which was built in
1150
nearby is the Petit Palais it was once
the residence of bishops and now houses
an art museum with an extensive
collection of works from the Middle Ages
and Renaissance a short stroll from the
cathedral is Rocher they'd own a park
with panoramic views of the wrong and
adjacent to the complex is the remnants
of the Saint Benezet bridge which once
spanned the Rhone today only four of the
original 22 arches remain but the
construction is solid enough that
tourists can still stroll along the span
luckily getting to Avignon is quite easy
and a well-developed tourism
infrastructure makes travel simple the
best way to avoid the crowds is to visit
in the spring or fall
[Music]